jennifer en 2009 a été une année
charnière pour toi dis que c'est l'année
où tu as intégré la star academy et en
plus de cela ça corresponde sortie du
tout du titre de kylie minogue can't get
you avec l'année 2001 je vous posais des
questions à chaque fois quatre
possibilités de réponses d'accord vous
allez devoir répondre avec la table
celui qui aura le plus de points à la
fin du jeu désignera celui qui devra se
déguiser en kylie minogue jusqu'à la fin
des missions dans la tenue de kate moss
marne en 2001 et les confettis dans
l'art est un philippin corse a marqué
l'émission par son comportement étrange
ce lequel est qui ce communiqué que
fantôme de ronan o'gara
il se prend pour un agent secret il mixe
seul dans son garage où il a mis des
jantes alu sur sa voiture et sa femme
nixon de sa non venue de ras-jedir c'est
terminé pour tout le monde on a la bonne
réponse c'était une très grande marque à
regarder la réponse en images
il ya beaucoup de c il ya beaucoup de b
il a arraché c'est quoi faire des jaloux
et ardue vu comme il a des petits jouets
pour le seco vendeuse quand philippe
rentrer enfin à la maison il file
directement dans sa pièce qui contient
son matériel etc pour s'entraîner à la
sono indifférent à la détresse de rémy
gimont à damas aurait massé chauffage
je ne suis pas malade
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la musique
je cherche un jeu lancé many fifa
d'elles était déjà dj je le faisais ça
j'avais acheté une chaîne hi-fi à
conforama je mettais les enceintes à la
fenêtre du sixième étage je mixais avec
ma table les messages pour faire genre
regardez je suis un chien chez corona
doctorale dont je faisais tout va mal se
passer pour un con dans la cité mais ça
j'allais me déçoit rémois nationaux
groupe exotisme
mais dans ce qui s'appelait exotisme
avec eux sont donc à la faisanderie
kitsch et ses animateurs du jackpot
offert à ouais ouais c'était alors on
était moins on était quatre serrières
est alors une autre belle en a qui vont
des aspirateurs
ouais ouais c'est vrai fan alors qu'ils
vendent estime wang c'est un gros
défenseur
on a un autre qui vend des tables à
repasser et il y en a un autre qui vend
du fabuleux c'est fabuleux mais c'est
resté des potes à judy ex madame jean
ouais j'en ai animé des mariages et bar
mitzvah des divorces aller en 2003 en
2001 qu'est ce qui se passe là le film
la vérité si je mens 2 qui sort fait
plus de 7 millions d'entrées dans une
des scènes du film le personnage de
serge pense ap une femme très ouverte
mais va nommer sur sa meilleure
bien sûr que va-t-elle prononcer quant à
va le reconnaître arrête de fréquenter
hanouna serge mais tu es fou
serge c'est toi mon fils ou mais
qu'est-ce qui prend jennifer puisque tu
l'as vu la vérité si je mens de saint
méard est est ce que là mais je vois
qu'elle ai dit je te s'il vous plaît
jennifer tu dis quoi lasser mais là
c'est oui oui mais tous disent et chez
vous aussi peut-être qui sait regarder
alors chez un copain geof
il m'a dit que tu aurais rien quand un
petit 5 à 7 avec un mec super bien monté
ça tombe bien chez un gros gros show de
la [ __ ]
tu sais quoi je te casse était petite
katarina
au feuilleton polochon tu attends ça
c'est toi mon fils manon
c'est les blacks comptaient fait qu'il
ait fait ça avec des potes sérieux ouais
je les fais mes potes bien sûr on le
faisait on était appelée de la mer il me
rappelle même à 3 heures du matin et non
pas six mois ou un jour j'ai appelé ma
mère mais qui dit sur la vie de ma mère
je suis à diriger un jour que celle vous
a dit un truc du genre j'ai envie de
bouffer plus ma mère alma le mcg et
marco du direct mais de m'insulter ma
mère je la connais je supprime clara mon
frère le lendemain peux te dire mal an
une planer mon frère je prenais
d'everett années m'ont choqué comment
s'appelle le tout premier tube delory
qui l'a fait connaître en 2001 ben
foster
je serai ta meilleure amie près de moi
les jeux
moi
je serai à ma belle j'adore ou bien je
sais près de moi
la censure a l'air l'aquilon
en rond sur les genoux il obama c'était
son make a wave chanteuse soul aux
philippines à la poste a renouvelé il a
arrêté sa carrière et maintenant il est
il vit là bas il a une boîte dct event
de tricks d'exactement îles philippines
chaussettes
alors à votre avis nous on n'a ni vous
êtes tous répondu à aubes et alors c'est
auprès de moi où je serai ta meilleure
amie
regardez on n'a pas la réussite
c'est ça gt ça fait plus d'un mois
[Musique]
ça
ils année
j'ai suivi aveuglément jennifer meyer
celaa et en fait c'était la maison mais
je préfère me trompe est d'avoir raison
avec douleur si vous êtes malade vous
restez chez vous je suis entraîné sept
parfums de mamie type mais non mais
c'est vrai il ya marine où il est il est
fort pas du tout c'est rien c'est passé
la naphtaline
c'est près de jeu a vu le jour le 10
mars 2001 je lis beaucoup d'examens
castaldi qui veut gagner des millions
fa si la chanter où attention à la
marche avec la question
[Musique]
sans quoi les huit ans
c'était avant sans compter la banlieue
mignot avoue avoir peur
[Musique]
c'est ce que je voulais jouer chez vous
quel jeu donc a vu le jour le 10 mars
2001 castaldi vous dites quoi attention
à la marche
vous êtes une encyclopédie de la télé
gagner des millions mais la vraie
encyclopédie la télé bien sûr c'est
isabelle isabelle mâché rien chanter
isabelle c'est qui veut gagner des
millions ou la vie il aurait dû tout ça
c'est juste pour faire quoi l'ami que
sont la marche ça attention là bas
[Applaudissements]
mission ou une candidate qui cela je
regardais c'est pour nous la kéran
écossais lé lock et messi c'est le
monstre au féminin à les confondre avec
elliott
il apparaît que sinon ça va comment vous
allez couple et tout ça mais on est en
direct vous savez
à l'époque déjà la question
[Musique]
vous avoir déjà fait
[Applaudissements]
gr crack dos au but alors je vous
rappelle cabinet pour fabien lecoeuvre
aquaboulevard sureau dans l'album de
roméo et juliette de la haine à l'amour
ça me rappelle ma relation avec valérie
bénaïm damien sargue interprète la
chanson les rois du monde
[Musique]
dans l'équipe locale il marche toujours
comme s'il était prise
[Musique]
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
si les rois du monde il interprète avec
sébastien château tom ross grégory de
mce et filipe da vila michel sardou et
cheb khaled ghanam est restée aux spas
et les ou là je vais vous séparer a fait
un coup de gourmettes des filets un coup
de gourmettes m non merci c'était une de
ces mots colère je rappelle qu'elle vend
des montres après alizé elles par suture
sur la plage à la tour eiffel à le
vendre ils ont l'habitude mais de petits
bonhommes là qui descendent n'y a pas
des souvenirs qui a pas des souvenirs
[Rires]
vous dites pour la ville a way to et ben
on n'a pas la vérification en images ah
non ça ne vient pas de la société qu'on
a racheté d'écouter de la musique
[Musique]
ensuite vous reconnaissez tout de suite
nationale
si tu as
merci bon très bon je sais pas pourquoi
on m'a mis un autre tube vu le jour en
2001 d'un artiste qui joue du clavier
comme personne alors je sais pas ce que
c'est
abbas en rigole mais je sais pas on m'a
millas donc à mon avis c'est qu'à une
femme on peut regarder sa venue toi
c'est vous
[Musique]
une demi heure
vous étiez censé imiter qui jean michel
jarre oui je ne sais même pas pas dû
faire ça à cinq minutes de la tête j'ai
dû dire ma vie parce que moi un truc
marrant puis fera nocéens très bien ok
alors on va voir qui est le plus de
points et ben c'est jean michel c'est
toute cette équipe là jean michel bénard
mal on va dire que c'est bening a gagné
[Applaudissements]
que tous ceux qui ont cinq points sont
sauvés les shérifs gagnant désigné un
qui n'a pas cinq points qui va être
tranquille et kylie minogue jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission là on a tout cinq
points ici c'est normal il lui en a
trois gars que nous sommes ici dans un
centre de leurs mots et isabelle
morini-bosc que raymond alors j'hésite
entre mon matthew raymond entre nous c
est maintenant pris on peut plus
aujourd'hui évidemment quarémont moi je
crois que je ne serai pas mal parce que
ça change et un mathieu et nador moi je
veux dire ça si je vais être très
honnête et j'ai pratiqué le moins de
points donc ça avec toi mais moi c'est
normal j'ai pas copier copine et mes
mots tu es ramener tout à l'heure et tu
verras
mais raymond tebani dans tout ça